I WILL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
YEAH I'M LIVING WITH THINK YOU
FILE ITEM TO.
SP FIFTEEN OH SIX I WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM MELINDA'S.
A SECOND FRONT CHIU.
CALL THE ROLL CRIPPLER OF.
BURKE I GROWTH BONTA CHIU.
GRAY MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I AM MULLIN DEUCE
MELINDA'S AYE. MULLIN QUIRK.
BURKE AYE VOEPEL. THE PANEL I.
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
I MEAN ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
YOU'RE GONNA
.
WHERE SHE DON'T? I WORK. WITH
WOMEN.
YOU KNOW THIS.
PLUS
.
EASY AS. WHERE WHERE'S AUTHOR
?
AND ARE
OF ABSENCE.
SO BRAIN BUT THE ABSENTEES ON
FILE ITEM TO.
BROUGH.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BRO I. BONTA GRAY MULLIN.
MULLIN I
.
CANCEL BILLION. OF TROUBLES ONLY
AND THE.
REALLY CLIENT WOMEN THEME.
TELLS ME EVERYTHING.
CAITLYN THINKS.
LANGUAGES AND.
GRAYSON.
HOW IT?
?
SENATOR MORE LIKELY DELAYED OPEN.
IS THE SUPPORT SUPPORT AND YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
OKAY GO IS HIGHLY WE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUT.
BOTH AS A SUPPORT.
NOW NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
HEALTH CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THINK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND TEN MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LARA BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THINKING.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WAS HIGHLY CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO A
PROPERTY AS INTENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
MELINDA'S MADE THE MOTION AND
QUIRK WE THANK YOU.
INTEREST IN.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO.
ALRIGHT THEN MOMENTS ARE GREEN
WE ADD THE STANDARD QUEUING
LANGUAGE PROVISIONS SPECIFIED
THAT THE NONPROFIT SHALL NOT USE
MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT OF MONIES
RECEIVED FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
PURPOSES. ADOPT TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN COMMENT SHE
OF THE COMMAND ALSO SURE
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS
CRACKED THINK YOU SIR.
DID A GREAT JOB MADAM CHAIR.
FOR I. FOR OUR AYE BROUGH. BRO I
BONTA.
BONTA RHS TO. CHIU ARE AYE GRAY
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN LISTS
MELINDA'S I MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK. QUIRK I'VE WILL TELL.
VOEPEL I. DON'T BILLS WITH THAT.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU SIR. YOU.
I CALLING ABSENTEES ON FILE ITEM
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MISS
AND CALL THE OF SEIZE BONTA AYE.
BONTA AYE.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
AS. IF THAT